In this section of our course, we will begin by exploring the MetaHuman Blueprint and we'll go through each of the components in detail.
We will take a close look at the skeletal meshes and rigs, the grooms, the LOD sync and MetaHuman component, rig logic, and the animation blueprints used by all MetaHumans.
All of the assets that can be found in the MetaHuman Blueprint are located inside of the MetaHuman's folder.
Let's begin by taking a look at what's inside the MetaHuman's folder and then we will delve into the MetaHuman Blueprint and all of its assets.
Once a MetaHuman has been exported from Quixel Bridge to Unreal Engine and all of the necessary plugin and project settings have been enabled, you can navigate to the MetaHuman's folder in the Content Browser.
The Common folder contains assets that are shared by some or all MetaHumans in a project.
Those assets include the shared MetaHuman-based skeleton for the body and the face archetype along with the skeletal meshes for the tops, bottoms, and shoes.
The Common folder also contains the face and body control rigs, the IK Retargetor assets, the FacePose library, and shared materials and textures.
The folder with the name of the MetaHuman that was added to the project will contain assets that are unique to that character.
Something to note is that it is not recommended to rename the MetaHuman's folder or move assets from existing folders such as the Common folder as they are referenced by other assets.
You can however duplicate assets and move or rename those copies if you wish.
Now let's jump into Unreal Engine and start exploring how all of these assets are brought together inside of the MetaHuman Blueprint.
Inside of Unreal Engine, in the viewport, we have the MetaHuman that we created from the RealityCaptureFaceScan data.
In the Content folder, let's navigate to the MetaHuman's folder and locate the folder for this character.
This character is named RCScan01 and I have added CQ to indicate that this was downloaded with the Cinematic Quality settings.
When we open up this folder, we will see the blueprint for this character. I will double click on this to open it.
Inside of the MetaHuman Blueprint, by default the Event Graph will be visible.
Over here we have the Construction script and over here we have the viewport where we can see our character.
Every MetaHuman has their own blueprint consisting of skeletal mesh components for the body, the feet, the legs, the torso, and the face.
Attached to the face are the groom components which are the eyelashes, the peach fuzz, the eyebrows, the hair, the mustache, and the beard.
Then there is the MetaHuman component which was added in Engine version 5.4 and this allows users to turn on and off animation features for each LOD
and the LOD Sync component which controls and synchronizes the switching of MetaHuman LODs.
Each of these components will have their own unique properties that will appear inside of the Details panel.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of the MetaHuman Blueprint.
Every MetaHuman has its own blueprint consisting of the following components.
The skeletal mesh components include the body, feet, legs, torso, and face.
The groom components include the hair, eyebrows, eyelashes, peach fuzz, mustache, and beard.
There is also the MetaHuman component which allows you to turn on and off animation features for each LOD and the LOD Sync component which controls and synchronizes the switching of MetaHuman LODs.
The construction script and event graph contain dedicated functions for ARKit and animation retargeting setups that can be customized.
Now let's take a closer look at each of the MetaHuman components.